es ist ein Kampf der verloren ist die
Ärzte können nichts mehr tun alisa ist
tot
und dann bricht die Welt zusammen für
baschirachmatt das Leben seiner Tochter
ist zu Ende nach gerade mal sieben
Jahren
[Musik]
tagelang hatte Alisa mit dem Fieber
gekämpft Malaria tagelang hatte die
Familie versucht einen Doktor zu finden
Medikamente
als sie im Krankenhaus von kaipur
landeten war es schon zu spät
der Weg zurück ins Dorf ist eine Qual
Bashir bringt sein totes Kind nach Hause
so viele Menschen in Pakistan müssen so
viel unerträgliches ertragen Vater
Bashir ist stark gewesen bis hierhin
oh bitte ja nicht sagen mehr als 1.500
Menschen sind tot ertrunken in der Flut
Krankheiten erlegen überall nur Schmerz
Verzweiflung
[Musik]
vor einer Woche ist schon mein Vater am
Fieber gestorben jetzt meine Tochter und
das alles nur weil wir hier keine Ärzte
und Krankenhäuser haben nur private und
die können wir nicht bezahlen ich will
nur eins sagen was wir erleiden sollte
niemand auf dieser Welt erleiden müssen
jeder muss doch Hilfe bekommen wenn er
krank ist
für jeden das ist Pakistans harter
Realität ist keine Hilfe da die
Dimension dieser Katastrophe ist einfach
zu groß überfordert das Land der Monsun
brachte viel mehr als den lang ersehnten
Regen erbrachte eine Sintflut 33
Millionen Menschen sind davon betroffen
das Dach über dem Kopf ist jetzt oft nur
noch ein Zelt wenn überhaupt die
Notlager sind voll
lebensmittelmedikamente das Ausland
unterstützt doch es reicht nicht und
auch wenn Helfer wie nur schabatterien
tun was sie können die Aufgabe scheint
übermächtig besonders weniger
Entzündungskrankheiten auf der Haut in
den Augen im Hals jeden Tag trifft es
mehr weil nicht mal die grundlegende
Gesundheitsversorgung gewährleistet ist
und die Menschen ertragen das mit großer
Kraft es ist herzzerreißend
es fehlt an allem sie leben in
unhygienischen Verhältnissen bekommen
nicht genug zu essen kein sauberes
Trinkwasser Schwangere stillende Mütter
kleine Kinder für sie ist es am
schlimmsten
nach dem Wasser schwappt nun eine
Infektionswelle über das Land von einer
zweiten Katastrophe spricht die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation
immer mehr
und wir können ja niemanden wegschicken
nach Hause schicken denn ein Zuhause
haben diese Menschen nicht mehr
unsere Behörden müssen sich schnell
darum kümmern ganze Dörfer müssen wieder
aufgebaut werden Häuser repariert werden
die Flut die die Berge des Himalaya
hinunterschoss war viel zu stark in
dieser Straße war sonst ein Markt da war
kein Fluss
Existenzen sind untergegangen das Wasser
steht ihnen bis zum Hals im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes
überleben das einzige was zählt viele
haben es nicht geschafft viele nur im
letzten Augenblick
und wo gestern noch Weizen wuchs wird es
keine Ernte geben
auf die höher gelegenen Straßen haben
sich viele gerettet hier harren sie aus
Tag und Nacht manche schon seit Wochen
und mit wenig Hoffnung schnell wieder
wegzukommen
das tägliche Brot lässt sich nicht mehr
verdienen sie sind auf Hilfe angewiesen
auch nasirachmatt und seine Frau Fatima
ihre acht Kinder das Haus der Familie
ist weg das Vieh ist tot die Felder die
nasiermal beackert hat sind abgesoffen
sie hatten sich etwas aufgebaut mühsam
arm waren sie immer aber es hat gereicht
um die Familie zu ernähren wenn sie
jetzt wieder anfangen müssen dann bei
Null
die Kinder meine Frau alle sind sehr
erschüttert es ist schlimm hier wir
können uns nicht waschen wir haben nicht
mal ein Bett zum schlafen wir liegen auf
dem Boden die Gnade unseres Propheten
hat uns zu diesem trockenen Platz
geführt ansonsten gibt es kaum einen
trockenen Platz auf Erden für uns
durch die Luft schwören die Moskitos
nicht mal vor denen gibt es Schutz auch
nicht vor den Krankheiten die sie
bringen
und am Morgen haben nasia und Fatima
eine Sorge mehr der
älteste Sohn hat Fieber
das macht mir Angst plötzlich ging es
ihm schlecht ich habe nur noch geweint
ein Doktor der Armee hat ihm inzwischen
eine Spritze gegeben wir sollen ihn am
besten schlafen lassen hat er gesagt
Pakistan ist Leid geprüft Krisen Kriege
und immer öfter bringt nun auch der
Klimawandel Not und Elend über Menschen
wieder
es ist nicht leicht Hoffnung bringen es
zu finden das Licht im Tunnel die
Ordnung im Chaos
hajimohamed Hanif versucht es es geht
ihm gut er hat ein Geschäft ist
wohlhabend und seiner Heimatstadt lahor
ist verschont geblieben von der Flut für
Hadschi wächst daraus seine
Verpflichtung er will helfen hat
Lebensmittel organisiert kümmert sich
selbst um die Verteilung
wenn wir das einfach so auf den Straßen
Abladen dann holen sich wenige Familien
alles und andere gehen völlig leer aus
so haben sie zuerst Gutscheine an die
Ärmsten verteilt für die es nun Pakete
gibt es soll gerecht zugehen
[Musik]
spüren die Last haben viel Arbeit vor
uns aber wir tun das für unsere Brüder
und Schwestern in Not für Sie und mit
Allahs Hilfe es ist eine Prüfung für uns
alle wir müssen der Gesellschaft dienen
und das ist auch ein Aufruf an die
Reichen unter uns helft in dieser Zeit
des Schmerzes
die Pakete werden sie über Wasser halten
für eine Weile sie tragen sie zurück
durch die Flut auf die Inseln die ihnen
geblieben sind auf denen sie überlebt
haben und überleben müssen
[Musik]